[Music]  hi gabby how did this cloud  certification journey begin for you  so it began because i wanted to have  limitless possibilities in my career and  i knew it a google class certification  will allow me to do that  and what was your key personal  motivation behind earning a google cloud  certification i wanted to master the  technology that is shaping our life  every day and for me google cloud  technologies and cloud technologies in  general they do that how would you  encourage someone new into the world of  cloud to set a goal of achieving a  google cloud certification  three things  the first thing  not that it can be done even if you  don't have the right cloud background  the right technology background it can  be done because i didn't  the second thing  is that accept  that  it's going to be hard it's going to  require a lot of sacrifice a lot of  commitment and discipline  and the third thing  know that  it's totally worth it  so  go for it